[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich bin koch vor etwa einem jahr haben
wir beschlossen einen kleinen wohnwagen
in einen food truck umzubauen wir
wollten etwas neues finden eine extra
motivation diesen job zu machen und dann
haben wir beschlossen es für die kunden
sie wollen nicht mehr
wollen lieber mit menschen kommunizieren
etwas besonderes wenn sie dafür stehen
in den letzten monaten haben sich in
unserem land und im ausland die
veranstaltungen zum thema streetfood
vervierfacht ziel ist es den trend der
zweite streetfood vorzustellen und
weiterzuentwickeln die leute haben immer
mit großer begeisterung ist neugierde
darauf reagiert
[Musik]
wir haben festivals besucht vor allem in
italien wir haben festivals in der
schweiz besucht wir haben gesehen was
die leute mögen die art von essen mit
einem guten geruch einem guten geschmack
wir haben uns angeschaut wie die
fahrzeuge aufgebaut sind welche farben
verwendet werden und dann haben wir
angefangen alles zu planen
[Musik]
viele menschen denken fälschlicherweise
dass man damit viel geld verdienen kann
ich denke ja ein lebensstil
die straße die leute und man lernt das
wahre leben in unserer gegend kennen
[Musik]
das ist eine gesellschaftliche bewegung
immer mehr menschen in unserem land
wollen sich selbstständig machen sie
sind nicht mehr zufrieden mit ihrer
arbeit in einem unternehmen wie in einem
restaurant weil es dort einen oder
mehrere manager gibt nun werden sie ihr
eigener manager sie tätigen ihre eigenen
investitionen sie gehen ihre eigenen
risiken ein aber ihre erfolge sind ganz
allein ihre sache
sie bringen ihre leidenschaft mitnehmen
wunsch ihre kochkünste zu zeigen
sigrid erlebt einen beispiellosen
aufschwung küchen in lieferwagen und
ständen tauchen auf sogar auf unseren
straßen diese art von tätigkeit ist
verlockend für diejenigen die sich in
diesem sektor betätigen wollen die
anfangsinvestition beträgt keine 50.000
euro das ist nichts im vergleich zu den
kosten und den bürokratischen
anforderungen
deren trend noch nicht gut definiert
sind ich hoffe dass vielleicht auf
kantonaler und kommunaler ebene ein paar
plätze organisiert werden wo alles mit
wachs gepackt werden können und wir auch
den rest des jahres arbeiten können
[Musik]
vorerst werden wir weiterhin auf messen
veranstaltungen konzerten sein und allem
was im sommer so stattfindet die
schwierigen zeiten kommen im winter denn
wir hatten gehofft einen festen standort
zu finden der uns ein regelmäßiges
einkommen garantiert
die gemeinden die bürokratie ist
christen es dauert sehr lange bis man
eine antwort bekommt die fast nie
positiv ist
bis vor zehn jahren hatten die gemeinde
nur mit gastronomen zu tun die
miteinander konkurrierten
jetzt ist eine neue art von fachleuten
aufgetaucht die eine ganz andere
struktur haben
und sie müssen über die pacht
entscheiden einige gemeinden haben angst
fehler zu machen und sind derzeit etwas
zurückhaltend bei der erteilung von
lizenzen
auch wenn das phänomen noch nicht weit
verbreitet ist werden wir in der übrigen
schweiz mit diesen neuen aktivitäten
konfrontiert wie fast immer von den
berufsverbänden der restaurants bekämpft
werden sie als unlautere wettbewerber
betrachten
genf und freiburg haben damit begonnen
öffentliche flächen für straßenküchen
zur verfügung zu stellen und einige
kantone sind bereits dabei sie
gesetzlich zu regeln street food bietet
die möglichkeit ethnische oder regionale
produkte zu essen ohne viel geld
auszugeben vor allem für junge leute und
es ist offensichtlich dass sich angebot
und nachfrage weiter vervielfachen
werden
streetfood sollte leicht zu essen sein
oder
also schneiden wir es sehen sie wie
einfach sie schneiden können man braucht
keine gabeln und messer
nun ja in meinem food truck wäre ich
etwas eleganter und würde sie auf einem
kleinen teller servieren das erste
street food in der geschichte geht auf
die ägypter zurück
in alexandria kamen die boote mit den
fischern
und der fisch wurde an ort und stelle
gebraten und an die fischer selbst
verkauft von dort aus ging es nach
griechenland und zu den römern street
food hat auch seine liebhaber sie
treffen sich bei den kochkursen von
viana pedrosa diagnose lag walker della
porta kanton reist gerne um die
authentische und populäre küche zu
entdecken streetfood ihre recherchen
führen und zu den ursprung und der
möglichen weiterentwicklung dieses
phänomens wie nennt man das
also ich zeige ihnen zwei verschiedene
arten die klassische mit fleisch soße
hier ist sie eine mahlzeit für sich das
geht auf die antike zurück es sieht aus
wie ein gericht aus essensresten
tatsächlich wurde es bei den
jagdgesellschaften der adligen serviert
damit sie eine gekochte mahlzeit
genießen konnten diese reisbällchen mit
gebratenen oder ihnen stammen aus
catania und sind nach normannischer art
zubereitet jeder aspekt des street food
ist sehr spezifisch das heißt ich gehe
dorthin weil ich zum beispiel ein ganz
bestimmtes sandwich essen möchte egal ob
es an einem marktstand angeboten wird
oder eben an einem lastwagen sie machen
dort in der regel nur ein paar wenige
gerichte aber die machen sie dann
richtig gut wenn du in palermo oder ein
genie fried erst dann machst du das die
ganze zeit und dann werden deine art
chemie wahrscheinlich auch die besten
sein weil du die übung hass und bei der
zubereitung einfach keine fehler mehr
macht
ich nehme sie jetzt mit nach asien
wir sind in thailand
wie erkennt man straßen essen wenn man
keine ahnung davon hat du kommst in ein
land und bist völlig ahnungslos du musst
verstehen wie die märkte funktionieren
was die verkäufer verkaufen was du
kaufen muss
aber wenn du dieses geräusch hörst
kannst du sagen dass das papaya salat
ist
denn es geht nur um schlagen und mischen
und du kannst dem verkäufer sagen nicht
zu scharf aber ihr schaf ist unser sehr
scharf
das interessante an street gut ist dass
man das essen der ganzen welt auf
knopfdruck bekommt
im vergleich zu früher ist es glaube ich
die größte veränderung und das was wir
am liebsten mögen es gibt auch leute die
lokale gerichte kochen aber sie auf der
straße sind wir und das mögen die leute
auch
ich stelle mir ein polenta standford das
könnte erfolgreich sein
oder eine suppen stand im winter wo man
hingeht
in den großstädten gibt es so was oft
und ich glaube dass es in unserem land
auf einer viel breiteren ebene ankommen
wird
denn die dir schon sagten die jungen
leute sind die größten kunden von street
food
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sagen wir ich habe das wenige geld das
ich hatte verwendet hätte nicht
ausgereicht und die stühle für ein
restaurant zu kaufen und dann habe ich
etwas hilfe von meiner familie bekommen
die mir den staat endlich hat
ich habe einen mietvertrag abgeschlossen
der mir geholfen hat das zu kaufen was
heute mein zuhause und meine
arbeitsplatz ist sozusagen
es war meine freundin die auf die idee
mit dem lkw kam
eines tages als sie sah dass ich ein
wenig verloren war teilte sie mit
da lag ich nicht sofort annahm aber nach
einer weile wurde mir klar dass es das
richtige zur richtigen zeit sein könnte
java api miamis karriere ist
außergewöhnlich er arbeitet im großen
restaurants in ganz europa darunter
eines der besten der welt das drei
sterne restaurant geranium in kopenhagen
heute finden wir ihn auf den märkten von
locarno lugano und bellinzona mit
persönlichen gerichten und im gegentrend
als ich erst gegründet habe war die
erste frage was willst du machen und ich
sagte nun ich möchte das menü jede woche
ändern er sagte zu mir du bist verrückt
es unmöglich niemand macht das und wenn
ich sowas höre dann spornt mich das an
für mich beginnt mein menü am donnerstag
hier in lokalen und dauert vier tage am
zweiten tag plane ich schon die nächste
woche denn es gibt viele dinge die ich
im laufe der jahre gelernt habe und die
mich zu dem koch gemacht haben der ich
jetzt bin und die ich unbedingt so oft
wie möglich umsetzen will
eine herausforderung besteht darin sich
durch die einzigartigkeit der gerichte
durch die techniken und die erfahrung
der gourmetküche hervorzuheben die für
alle erschwinglich ist wie wir weiterhin
den job macht den er liebt
das schöne an meinem food truck ist dass
sich um 4.30 bis 5 uhr morgens aufwachen
und bis 37 arbeiten kann und meine
sachen zu produzieren in meinem
restaurant kann man das nicht es sei
denn man wohnt darüber man kann nicht um
fünf uhr morgens hingehen und einfach zu
arbeiten für mich ist das wichtig also
mein privatleben mit meiner arbeit
vereinbaren kann
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja
[Musik]
[Applaus]
in palermo der italienischen hauptstadt
des street treffen wir uns erneut mit
bibiana pedrosa
der geschmack von knorpel und fett ist
sehr delikat
erwarten sie keinen starken geschmack
meiner meinung nach schmeckte svi
hühnerhaut
hier in palermo ist das trikot zu einer
touristenattraktion geworden es gibt
spezialisierte führer die spaziergänge
über die märkte und die haupt plätze des
historischen zentrums organisieren und
die gelegenheit bieten die spezialitäten
der besten fritten boden und straßen
stände zu probieren und die stadt so zu
erleben wie es die einwohner palermos
jeden tag tun
[Musik]
dass straßen essen ist eine der
grundlagen der kultur von palermo bei
street sagen wir immer dass ein paneele
sandwich die geschichte palermos erzählt
genauso wie die kathedrale die kirche la
macarena oder der kapo kanti
wenn sie also palermo besuchen und das
essen nicht probieren ist es als wären
sie nie in palermo gewesen
theo pijper
bist du der beste mozart in palermo auf
der ganzen welt auf der ganzen welt
wo anders auf der welt nicht arrogant
sein und an geben aber das wird
nirgendwo anders gemacht
also bin ich der beste auf der ganzen
welt
das ist die berühmteste spezialität von
palermo sie repräsentiert palermo viel
mehr als das opernhaus
[Musik]
die männer ihrer messe
platz
[Musik]
detroit
allg
er spielte
[Musik]
1952 verkaufe ich will sun lodges wir
haben ja man könnte schon gesehen ich
bin bescheiden also ich es nicht sagen
aber ich bin auf dem gipfel der kunst
sich bestätigen
[Musik]
wenn man das können eines sizilianischen
kochs genau beobachtet ist das mehr wert
als tausend die kochbücher wir machen 13
pfund pro tag wie viele reisbällchen
sind das
eine menge
[Musik]
das strassen sm palermo scheint dem
ansturm der großen ketten zu trotzen die
berühmtesten amerikanischen ketten haben
es versucht aber sie hatten immer nur
die teenager im auge also hält das
streetfood dagegen schon seit 2006 100
jahren und wir hoffen dass es noch lange
dagegen halten wird
was sie da haben ist eine art offen das
ist ein gas rufen und dann habe ich die
fahne und sie mal
fantastisch ein bisschen öl das ist
typisch für palermo er ist 100 jahre alt
er ist schon sehr weit
dann werden die gebackenen morgens
werden abends gebacken ich kaufe dies
sind schon alle in palermo die sind
schon um machen kaufen sie wie viele
machen sie am tag und dann pro tag ein
gast der hierher nach palermo kommt und
sie probieren will hat ein problem denn
er wird sie immer essen macht es süchtig
ja sommer oder winter du bist immer hier
das ist arbeit dass es das brot meines
sohnes
das ist der typische sven zone von
palermo meine damen und herren es
gehabt um ja sie ist süße als normal
sehr gut
[Musik]
ich komme schon zum nächsten mal nach
palermo um das authentischste street zu
finden palermo ist eine küche unter
freiem himmel es gibt trauer geschrei
leute die kochen menschen die essen
jedes gericht erzählt von der
vergangenheit von den arabern ein stück
brot mit sesam darauf erzählt von der
arabischen herrschaft und palermo hat es
geschafft sich in alles einzufügen nicht
wahr im vergleich zu anderen völkern
haben die ganzen einflüsse hier die
kultur bereichert
das sind doch wenn ich mich nicht irre
die krake dieses dokument man riskiert
oder mit canella kartoffeln und roten
zwiebeln wird das alles miteinander
vermischt
[Musik]
ja es ist mehr panella als kartoffel
weil es mit dem gemacht wird was in der
pfanne für die pennäler übrig bleibt
früher war es ein arme-leute-essen
und heute heute ist es für alle nicht
jeder mag das wie viel öl verwenden sie
am tag 3,4 bis 37 gallonen dann muss man
es ja oft wechseln jeden tag
ich probiere zuerst mal ich glaube ihre
sind die leckersten oder
[Musik]
sehr gut
was ist das fleisch brötchen mit panini
sammelbilder schinken käse rosinen salz
und pfeffer
das sind die sticky ole was sie probiert
es sind kalbs innereien das ist alles
kein fleisch isst schweinebauern zwiebel
und es heißt essen und trinken warum
essen und trinken weil die zwiebel
ziemlich stark und wenn man sie probiert
muss man trinken muss trinken
wie kommt es dass man in der
sizilianischen küche hauptsächlich fisch
erwartet obwohl es so viel fleisch gibt
das hätte niemand erwartet wir sind
kannibalen aber wir kochen unser schmerz
ohne ein tablett
[Musik]
ich war acht jahre alt als ich mit
diesem job anfängt
mit acht jahren bin ich zur schule
gegangen und habe gearbeitet
ich habe geheiratet ich habe eine frau
ich habe kinder jetzt bin ich großvater
und ich bin immer noch ja hat sich nie
jemand über den rauch beschwert
er beschwert sich denn nur die
stadtverwaltung tut das
wollen nicht dass wir auf der straße
kochen aber das essen auf der straße
beginnt sollte es auch draußen sterben
[Musik]
ein muss für liebhaber des abendlichen
street food ist die historische und sehr
über filter bocelli
auch wenn sie schon immer geduldet
wurden sind alle diese straßenküchen
nicht wirklich zugelassen
gedünsteter octopus du bist also ein ein
blutbad wie lange werden die gedünstet
die sind ja in zehn minuten aber mit
dieser pfanne das ist der traditionelle
topf aus palermo er hat keinen boden
und damit kocht es sich noch besser
ist er schon geschlagen nein das machen
wir nicht ihr schlagt ihn nicht in
apulien schon wir schlagen andere dinge
aber nicht den tintenfisch nein wie
viele schworen sie am tag am abend 33
punkte und genau
die jungen leute interessieren sich
nicht für diese traditionelle arbeit es
ist eines der alten handwerke dass
niemand mehr machen will weil es ihnen
peinlich wäre gedünsteten tintenfisch zu
verkaufen sie suchen sich lieber einen
bürojob oder sitzen auf einem liegestuhl
aber die familien können mit dieser
arbeit ihren lebensunterhalt verdienen
das sind sie erdbeeren
[Musik]
zeil war der oktopus poet
wie viel verlangen sie für ein solches
gericht fünf euro das ist wirklich nicht
so viel fünf euro für den octopus egal
wie groß das hängt von seinem gewicht
aber
zuerst schaue ich mir die leute an und
wenn sie mir sympathisch sind
auf diesem platz ist es wie in einem
theater man kommt hierher wegen der
typischen und preiswerten spielen den
gedünsteten tintenfisch den gegrillten
den gefüllten sardin aber vor allem weil
das sizilianische straßen essen jeden
fesselt fasziniert und erobert
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das essen auf der straße ist eine so
angenehme und köstliche erfahrung dass
einige spezialitäten heute auch in den
restaurants zu finden sind
es ist schön zu sehen wie die
parlamentarische streetfood tradition
die restaurants in palermo selbst
erreicht und dann sogar ins ausland
exportiert wird
das gibt denjenigen die nicht wie die
palermitaner durch die märkte und
straßen der stadt ziehen können die
möglichkeit street food in einem
klassischen rahmen hier in einem
restaurant zu genießen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
london eine dynamische stadt die in
vielen bereichen eine art trend setter
ist hier hin folgen wir wie diana
ghettos der köchin die unterwegs ist um
herauszufinden was in den faqs und an
den ständen der englischen metropole
passiert
[Musik]
was sollen wir heute probieren ihr
lieblingsessen ich würde den couscous
probieren eigentlich habe ich ihnen
schon probiert das ist mit tun das ist
mit paprika
sehen sie sie verwenden frische zutaten
an den asiatischen ständen sind oft
asiaten und das gibt ihnen eine
vorstellung davon wie beliebt sie sind
wenn es diese touristen die sie
probieren aber auch einheimische
verschiedener nationalitäten oder
jedenfalls aus dieser gegend
nehmen sie manchmal auch was mit ins
büro
auf keinen fall wenn es nicht gerade
regnet oder überschwemmt ist haben wir
eine stunde pause in der man spazieren
geht und im freien
im winter kann man es mit ins büro
nehmen die jungs und normalerweise gut
ausgerüstet um es einzufangen
london hat ein abwechslungsreiches
gastronomisches angebot voller
überraschung unter den straßenständen
erwarte ich hauptsächlich asiatische und
multi ethnische spezialitäten aber es
gibt auch noch platz für traditionelle
rezepte die unseren europäischen gaumen
viel näher sind wie zum beispiel die tat
flat
mein rezept ist ein wenig geheim aber
sagen wir wir haben gekochte kartoffeln
karamellisierte und sortierte zwiebeln
einige schinken würfel und den hublot
chance da die grundlage des rezept das
ganze wird mit creme doubles
[Musik]
eines abends machte ich papierrollen mit
meinem mann und gepackten ein paar
zutaten dazu es sei sofort nach spaß aus
und war gleichzeitig eine gesunde und
ausgewogene mahlzeit
sie machen spaß man ist sie mit denen
wir sprachen neun monate lang darüber
und irgendwann kündigte ich dann bei
pepsico durch einen schönen und
wichtigen job hatte ich war leitende
produktmanagerin das ist also eine große
herausforderung für uns
es war ein großes risiko alles
aufzugeben aber das ist mein neues leben
[Musik]
auf der anderen seite kann man in london
alles finden sogar eine variation der
klassischen rosa gebratene japanische
teigtaschen die von köchen zubereitet
werden die noch nie in japan waren
trotzdem sind ihre geos äußerst beliebt
es ist gut aber ich hätte keine
mayonnaise genommen
[Musik]
das street food hat sich hier parallel
zur krise entwickelt ein anspruchsvolles
kosmopolitisches publikum und viele
dynamische menschen die in diesem
bereich einen fruchtbaren boden gefunden
haben der offen ist für kulinarische
überraschung
[Musik]
hallo zusammen dass ich einmal
überprüfen ob du die hygiene und
sicherheitsvorschriften einhält
kannst du mir die dokumente geben die
das bescheinigen
ja das ist gut
so perfekt
das ist auch gut
wo ist das waschbecken
okay wir hinten
großartig vielen dank wo ist der
feuerlöscher hier ist ich danke ihnen
vielmals
es ist sehr wichtig dass die hygiene und
sicherheitsvorschriften für streetfood
genauso gelten wie für restaurants hörer
prüfen rund zwölf dokument es gibt von
der anmeldung der angewandten methoden
bis zu den sicherheitsverpflichtungen
überprüfen ob sie in ordnung sind mit
alles so ist wie es sein sollte jeder
wird jede woche kontrolliert sie müssen
die küchen ja immer wieder auf- und
abbauen und jeder der hierher kommt um
seine produkte anzubieten muss verstehen
dass wir in gruppen arbeiten dass wenn
wir heute hier morgen street sind es
auch andere märkte wie diesen in london
gibt und sein irgendwo etwas schiefgeht
sind wir alle involviert
trotz des anscheins ist hier alles sehr
gut organisiert
dieser markt in stand vor sieben jahren
und findet nur an den wochenenden statt
aber er hat ein viertel im südosten
londons wieder belebt ist sehr beliebt
bei menschen die gerne ungewöhnliches
essen ausprobieren
wir haben jedes wochenende 10.000
besucher aber in den ersten beiden
jahren gab es mehr straßenküchen als
kunden
das geheimnis liegt darin bereiche zu
nutzen in die die menschen normalerweise
nicht gehen würden und diesen ort neues
leben einzuhauchen
heute pulsiert diese gegen mit vielen
geschäften und unternehmen
wir waren die ersten aber heute gibt es
kneipen bars restaurants und geschäfte
dank der energie die verlieren losging
gehörgang
hallo wenn es ihnen nichts ausmacht
würde ich gerne eine hygiene inspektion
durchführen wie ist das für einen koch
auf der straße zu arbeiten
das ist ganz anders im winter bei minus
acht grad ist es wirklich kalt und man
hat nicht den komfort und die wärme
eines richtigen küchenherdes was
angenehm ist
ich vermisse die richtige küche ein
bisschen mit zehn köchen um mich herum
und so
aber hier bin ich verantwortlich
hier arbeite ich mit meiner frau
zusammen und das gefällt uns
wir haben verloren
nach meinem abschluss in
wirtschaftswissenschaften habe ich in
einer bank in der stadt gearbeitet und
ich hatte glück dass ich eine stelle
fand denn es gab nicht allzu viele
jobangebote
aber ich muss ehrlich sagen dass mir die
arbeit in der bank nicht gefiel war
nichts für mich zwar nicht das was sie
machen wollte aber ich sage immer wieder
diese netten jungs mit ihrem ofen auf
die straße kamen und eines tages sah ich
einen von ihnen der in einer stunde 3
100 mahlzeiten verkaufte ich schaute mir
seine speisekarte an und sagte mir
verdammt viel dieser typ verdient eine
menge geld werden wir in der bank nicht
so viel verdienten also habe ich
gekündigt und angefangen t zu verkaufen
oder bei viel gelernt vor allem was man
nicht tun sollte heute organisiere und
leite ich verschiedene märkte wie diesen
sondern und ich möchte nichts anderes
machen denn wir sind wie eine große
familie
[Musik]
in london sind der wettbewerb und die
auswahl sehr groß aber einige verkäufer
haben eine lösung gefunden die den
standard für genehmigungen setzt und für
die suche nach privilegierten gebieten
riesen im finanzviertel canary wharf
sie haben sich in einer vereinigung
zusammengeschlossen wie zb der körper
täglich viele märkte in der stadt
veranstaltet und ihre mitglieder nach
der qualität ihres angebots auswählt
wir präsentieren uns alle zusammen als
gruppe nicht als einzelne anbieter die
körper wirkt für uns macht uns bekannt
in vor allem schafft sie es uns an
diesen unglaublichen orten zu platzieren
es wäre unmöglich allein einen solchen
ort im zentrum von london zu finden
ein indisches sandwich weit weg von
indien das von der zeitschrift time out
als eines der besten in london
bezeichnet wurde
wir haben unabhängig angefangen aber es
war unser ziel teil vom körper zu werden
weil sie sehr hohe qualitätsstandards
für street haben wir überzeugten sie da
von uns in die gruppe aufzunehmen
nachdem sie unsere gerichte probiert
hatten wir brachten sie zu den managern
einiger ihrer märkte erklärten unserer
philosophie unsere marke und wer wir
sind und
nach einem monat wurden hier aufgenommen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sprechen sie griechisch na klar und sie
nur ein paar worte
baraka
disco in ostia der aus den usa stammende
spiros bekannt als begriff krieg ist bei
den fans von souvlaki moussaka gyros und
anderen griechischen spezialitäten sehr
beliebt jeden tag ist er mit seinem
lieferwagen auf den märkten der coop
gruppe unterwegs und hat auch einen
kleinen stand auf dem überfüllten multi
ethnischen markt von kempten town
[Musik]
viele leute kommen aus der ganzen welt
hierher um unser modell zu kopieren
in london konnte sich das streetfood
relativ frei entwickeln also wollen sie
das modell nach das ist eine wunderbare
sache
rostock
oder auch nicht fotografiert
ich habe als koch in new york angefangen
aber in vielen restaurants und privat
clubs gearbeitet
dann habe ich meine frau kennengelernt
und wir sind nach london gezogen
habe ich sechs monate lang im hotel ritz
gearbeitet
dann wurde ich chefkoch für große
wirtschaftsmanager da fing ich an meinen
job unerträglich zu finden ich habe ihn
nur wegen des geldes gemacht und nicht
aus freude am kochen
also beschloss ich etwas anderes zu
machen ich wusste nicht mal das street
geht
ich habe recherchiert und herausgefunden
dass es hier niemanden gibt der
griechische street gemacht
und das ist meine wahl
griechischer joghurt gurken knoblauch
salz essig und fans
findest du es ist als wäre man in athen
wirklich einige griechen haben mir
gesagt es sei besser als in athen ich
habe vielen dank gesagt dass das beste
aller komplimente dafür mache ich das
nächster halt ist des mittelfelds markt
wo jeden tag hunderte von menschen bei
jedem wetter schlange stehen um ein
leckeres mittagessen aus einer großen
auswahl zu bekommen
[Musik]
das ist eine parlamentarische adam china
in london
herzlichen glückwunsch sie es scheint
als wäre die londoner mittagspause
gleichbedeutend mit streetfood aber auf
der suche nach qualität
für 67 und kann man in jeder andere
pizzeria gehen sich an den tisch setzen
und pizza essen hier nimmt man sie mit
oder man schaltet sie meistens sind es
italiener oder sie essen sie im stehen
und
so was zu tun bedeutet dass sie unser
produkt wirklich zu schätzen wissen
westrum alando ist 27 jahre alt kommt
aus pescara und hat sich sofort einen
namen gemacht mit seinen die in zwei
umgebauten lieferwagen echten holzöfen
macht er bereitet schon einen dritten
vor aber sein erfolgsrezept
sind vor allem die zu tragen
glücklicherweise können wir all unseren
hochwertigen produkte aus italien
beziehen auch das holz es kommt aus vor
misano in der nähe von neapel hier
kaufen wir nur das basilikum das in
italien jetzt sehr heiß ist wir haben
jemanden der es aus italien mit brachte
aber es wurde ganz schwarz und wir
konnten es nicht verwenden also
beschlossen wir es hier in england zu
kaufen
da viele kunden im finanzbereich
arbeiten kam es vor dass die besten
street food konzepte zu einer art
startup wurden die mädels die
aufmerksamkeit potenzieller investoren
auf sich
nach drei oder vier monaten hier ins
mittelfeld bekamen wir einige wirklich
tolle angebote von investoren
ich habe immer versucht sie abzulehnen
weil ich gerne langsam wachsen möchte um
die qualität unserer produkte zu
erhalten
etwas das ein großes unternehmen nicht
tun würde die packen alles möglich auf
ihre pizzen
[Musik]
spektakulär wirklich gut da ist der süße
kürbis die schärfe der salzige käse es
gibt einen der fast fertig ist mit
saudischem pecorino
ist so alt wie mein vater ein bisschen
alt aus rom nein er ist aus umbrien er
ist aus rom und er macht hähnchen am
spieß
er ist ein wirklich netter kerl da
drüben ist spanien er ist materie
ich bin italienerin
sie machen eine wunderbare bei
meiner meinung nach ist streetfood so
fesselnd weil die risiken begrenzt und
kontrollierbar sind
weil ein fahrzeug auf rädern bewegt
werden kann während ein restaurant
irgendwo fest sitzt
und man muss dem bereich für die
potenziellen kunden überwachen aber
mit einem food truck kann man es sich
leisten es auszuprobieren und wenn es
nicht klappt kann man es am nächsten tag
woanders versuchen
das talent von silvestre und seinen
jungs ist es den pizzateig fliegen zu
lassen und jeden tag mit leichtigkeit
und geschick eine einfache und populäre
speise in kulinarische kunst zu
verwandeln
[Musik]
beim schlendern entlang der stände denke
ich darüber nach warum das street in
london ein so hohes niveau erreicht hat
die extrem hohe qualität das vielfältige
angebot die größere anziehungskraft als
die der klassischen restaurants und vor
allem die große publikumsresonanz
hier hat die wahre entwicklung des
street food stattgefunden vom einfachen
straßen essen zu einem organisierten und
erfolgreichen system es ist wie in china
chinesischer geschmack perfekt
[Musik]
die welt des street food ist in
ständiger bewegung und seine zukunft
scheint auch in unserem land
vielversprechend zu sein
die zukunft des street food der die
zukunft ist eigentlich die gegenwart wir
brauchen bei bestimmten dingen etwas
mehr zeit aber ich glaube dass wir einen
kompromiss mit der gastronomie finden
müssen
denn im grunde müssen wir erst einmal
verstehen dass niemand der konkurrent
von irgendjemandem manhattan gibt es 15
millionen menschen straßenverkäufer und
restaurants und alle arbeiten also kann
es klappen
ich bin in der kochkunst das restaurant
ist eindeutig in der koch im hotel auch
der lebensmittelhändler schließlich
machen wir alle denselben job wir sitzen
alle im selben boot wenn wir nicht
miteinander kooperieren leute es ist
unmöglich weiter zu machen
[Musik]